foreign
[Music]
people burning
everything destroyed it was Athena she
was doing it
I was doing it we won't let that happen
I saw what you did in the ring
I knew it had to be you say it
what if I told you Sienna here is The
Reincarnation of the goddess Athena
and you are destined to become one of
her Guardian Knights
how does it feel to be a goddess
sometimes I feel like I'm a guest in my
own body
are you ready to start your training the
Pegasus night is Brave
humble and committed to protecting
Athena with his life
what the hell did you do that
like any other before
I am save the rest of us from her
you think I wanted any of this
Powers liability once he learns to
control it no living man will be able to
stop
you might want to buckle up
though you were the only night in town
[Music]